[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalist ryan we are the
most technologically advanced society in
history
and yet we've never been more anxious
medicated and lonely
as today's guest says we have a thousand
facebook friends
but no one to help us move our couch um
today on the public podcast we're
talking about the loneliness epidemic
with dr john deloney jeff thanks for
being here what's up everybody what's up
man thanks for being here man this is uh
yeah you're doing awesome work i can't
wait to dive into it yes indeed we got a
lot to dive into this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast john and ryan
and i we're going to talk about anxiety
we're going to talk about the bricks in
your backpack we're going to talk about
thought terminating cliches
we talked about a lot on that maximal
episode you can check that out this
thursday
patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
i love it man alabama we got a question
here from patreon maria has a question
for us how can you tell if you're
feeling lonely
i enjoy spending time with people but i
used to be very codependent and i worry
about falling back into old habits john
can you break down some of these words
codependent what does that mean also how
do we recognize loneliness because
sometimes we've been told that we're
lonely even if we're not yeah so i think
codependency is is when my needs are met
by meeting your needs and your needs are
endless and you get to dictate what
those needs are and my life my my
purpose my meaning in the world is made
complete only when
i can shove all of the things i need and
believe down just to make sure you're
all okay right that's codependency
totally different than lonely right
lonely is simply our bodies
biomechanical recognition that you are
disconnected from other people
i have had seasons of profound loss i've
been married we'll celebrate our 20th
anniversary this year
um
wonderful wonderful woman i've had
seasons of profound loneliness sharing a
bed with somebody that i know loves me
right i've found myself in a crowded
room completely and totally alone or
sitting at a table where everyone's
laughing
and there's that it's almost that
pullback right it's that i'm here on a
planet all by myself and so i think
loneliness can be spiritual it can be
physical it can be all those things but
it's when our bodies recognize you are
out on an island my friend you are all
alone yeah well and there's nothing
wrong with loneliness i mean you know
the question kind of pauses like
well i don't know if i'm lonely
uh meaning that like you know how do i
know that i'm uh you know doing the
right thing or or you know conversely
i'm doing the wrong thing
i would say loneliness is being able to
sit with loneliness is uh it's a
superpower in a way yeah it's like being
able to sit with boredom um i remember
when we moved to missoula montana um
josh you know he would go see movies by
himself he'd go eat by himself and i'm
like
what a freaking psychopath like what
does he do you're gonna see murdering
children right like man he's a yeah he's
a very high functioning sociopath
and then i i actually started to envy
the fact that um he could be by himself
and enjoy this time just watching the
movie or going out to eat so i i went
out on my way to be lonely and um it
turns out i really like myself
i'm a pretty cool guy i'm the coolest
guy amen yeah kapil gupta says all
conflict is self-conflict
and
it's fascinating because we all have
different personalities and those
personalities often dictate our needs
you know you if you look like a
myers-briggs ryan and i are literally
exact opposites and i'm an istj ryan is
an enfp so literally the exact opposite
that's right and he's the most
extroverted person i know i'm the most
introverted person i know i married with
a kid i probably spent 90 percent of my
time alone
and
part of that for me was setting an
expectation with the people around me
because before what did i try to do i
tried to conform
to the way other people behave oh ryan
is so outgoing i should be
like him you have any idea how many
strip clubs i brought josh to against
his will
and so
what what i recognized is that my
desires are going to be different from
ryan's it doesn't make me wrong in fact
the only wrong thing here is if i try to
conform to his way of living i actually
felt more lonely
in those scenarios than if i were to
retreat into a place by myself where i
can be alone and comfortable with being
alone and not feel lonely at all so
there is a difference between
individuality and isolation we talked
about that a bit on the maximal episode
this week but there's also a difference
between being alone
and being lonely
the underneath everything you all both
mentioned is this one word that just
pulses through our ethos it's it it
doesn't pull through these it's gone it
needs to come back and that's
intentionality
if i am intentional about my body's need
for solitude if i know my surroundings
enough to know i have such deep
relationships with my child with my
spouse my girlfriend whatever that i'm
anchored in
so that
i can go into a season of solitude by
myself or 90 of my time i would say
being a well person you've got to be
anchored into a community of groups so
that i can go be well over here and vice
versa here so i think to me it's it's
about intentionality and again i could
be in proximity to somebody that i care
deeply about
but i hadn't done the work outside of
that particular moment to remain
connected here and so i find myself
lonely right i think solitude is a
practice we've lost yeah is being okay
with yourself that's when the noise
stops and we're not okay and we race to
fill it with the noise
um i have found i can only have seasons
of good solitude when my relationships
are okay otherwise it becomes a drug it
becomes pathological i start hiding
uh so the difference between solitude
and hiding
is one is protective one is restorative
okay we got a question here from katie
on facebook how do you make friends as
an adult oh it's the worst tender it's
the worst
there's no swipe right for like 40 year
old dudes who are like uh hey man like
it doesn't it's the worst it's the worst
it's the worst
um so when we're kids we just get
dropped into
a classroom and it's like y'all are all
about the same smartish or something and
you're the same age figure it out yeah
yes y'all said kickball y'all we're all
playing and either you found community
like kickball stupid for idiots or i'm
gonna win the game right whatever
you you found community cause you just
got dropped in a box and then in middle
school same thing and then high school
it starts to branch out i'm old enough
now that it used to be like are you a
kicker are you like in hip-hop or you're
like a metal head are you in music you
in sports whatever you had to like
identify your game what's your tribe
what's the tribe
and then you get dumped out into the
world after college and then it says
not only are you on your own but they're
all against you ready go and you're 21
and you're like okay man you show up to
the office and that dude's 54 and she's
48 and it's like it's killer be killed
my brother you know me and then it's on
and our bodies go ah because we're not
designed to do life like that right and
so
i have found the only way and this is
the worst man i wish there was some cool
sexy like sleek way to package this it's
not
it's the old ester perel wisdom every
relationship is a risk
and you are worth the risk
and so at 40 i have to recognize i will
die a slow miserable death of despair if
i don't have other people that i'm doing
life with
either 90 of the time or 10 of the time
right
and i got to take that risk yeah i got
to take that risk i got to step into it
i got to be hospitable i got to invite
people over to my house i got to say
this is just i'm not going to clean up
you all come over
and if they want to opt out of my messy
house that's on them and that's a whole
other conversation but but i have to
take that risk oh yeah period full stop
yeah this is making me think uh
there needs to be an app for people who
are just looking for friends yes like
this is like you know it's very clear
like this is not a dating site
this is for people who need to find
friends with similar interests but then
it makes me think about uh meetup
i think it's meetup.com or maybe it's
dot org
but you know you can literally go to
this website
and look at different topics and be like
oh i'm interested in
heavy metal and here's a whole group
that's interested in heavy metal oh and
they meet locally you know every
thursday night or whatever i have no
idea this app exists it's for real yes
this is for real yeah i'm looking in the
camera if
don't screw this up predators let people
go meet their people that's so great
yeah there's always one idiot that
screws up these meetups don't be that
god you know i actually haven't um i
haven't heard of any now that you
mentioned that like i'm surprised i
haven't heard of any like really crazy
things i am going to try it but like no
my uh my my wife was using it for coders
um like basically there's this whole
code coding community community in los
angeles that she would go and um she
would like get feedback on her code and
like she would you know learn things
from other people's code um but yeah i
mean there are ways to to uh make
friends as an adult but john you're
right man like it is absolutely a risk
and you have to be willing to take that
risk and you know what you're probably
going to fail
enough probably 100 percent yeah and
it's okay it's okay it's okay to like
put yourself out there
and uh and and the relationship not go
where you wanted it to go the friendship
to not go where you wanted it to go and
i think it's important to realize like
when it doesn't go the way you want it
it's not your fault it just is it
doesn't make that person bad
or or you bad it's just it wasn't a
friendship match that's okay we've
turned every relationship into
like into the super bowl right like
if like this is it and if we screw this
one up it's it's over for you dude
you'll never cut
so dumb man lebron james tonight will
take i don't even know lakers may be out
so i was trying to do a local reference
but let's pretend they were still in
they're still playing right and he would
take two or three hundred shots before
the game started because he's practicing
yeah he's practicing
so that he can take shots during the
game that count and he's gonna miss most
of those yeah and he's still going to
hall of fame
dude go hang out with a group of coders
man my wife has a writing group and they
give each other feedback on their stuff
and they have shared experiences they
earn each other's trust over time they
all know dude when ryan gives feedback
we all know ryan's kind of great like
right that's just kind of the gang but
he also brings the good beers and so
he's right so you develop your ethos and
then man there's going to be times it
just doesn't work and you got to say all
right i'm practicing i'm going to try
again next time and i'm going to go
about it again and i'm going to go about
it again i'm going to go about it again
cannot do life alone and the best way to
foster a friendship i feel like is
don't look for what you can get from
that relationship look what you can give
yes to that relationship show up yeah
yeah and it becomes less risky in those
scenarios as well so we recognize that
there is a risk but it's not the same
risk that we associate with
camping in the woods for a month
straight you know it's like oh i might
get eaten by some bear right but we we
associate that same anxiety that same
stress level with meeting a new person
right and so that risk is about the same
as wearing two different shoes on you
know i'm wearing an orange shoe here and
a black shoe on this foot
there's no real risk in that other than
the judgment of others
but for many of us that is the most
terrifying thing why is that the most
terrifying thing because we are the main
character in our story we think we are
you know whomever the we think we're the
steve mcqueen in our story but but
really like we're all just extra sort of
hanging out in the background no one
really cares to the level that we think
they care even for someone like me and
ryan who are relatively well known and
people recognize us in public
it most they'll recognize it but then
they go on to drinking their smoothie or
whatever it is they don't actually care
to the level that we think people are
obsessing over us because we obsess over
ourselves and it's easy to understand
why we do that our world view is our
world view i see everything like i'm
looking into my camera right i'm talking
into my microphone i'm looking at my
computer talking to my wife or my
daughter right and it's everything
through my own world view i will say one
one way we do get caught up and i think
it makes it more difficult we
accidentally make finding friends more
difficult as an adult we look for
someone who is like-minded
right it means they have the same
beliefs they have the same
world view they have the same
preferences same hobbies same
personality well you are creating these
sort of prison walls and it's going to
be a very small cell that you're stuck
in so instead of finding someone who is
like-minded i seek out people who are
open-minded we might have different
beliefs we might have different
religious traditions wisdom traditions i
found one of the the best ways ryan and
i were in on tour in 2014 we went to a
hundred cities and people were coming up
to us afterward it's great you guys were
here for two hours now you're leaving
yeah well how am i supposed to connect
with other open-minded people like this
and we didn't have an answer until 2014
we left behind a hundred free local
meetup groups a hundred cities eight
different countries so if you're
interested in connecting with
open-minded people and katie i don't
know if you're in one of these cities
it's 100 cities across the world
minimalist.org you can go on there it's
like meetup.com but for people who are
interested in simplifying it could be
simplifying your stuff but your career a
whole bunch of different other areas in
your life being more intentional
connecting with other intentional people
minimalist.org is a great place to do
that if there's not a city near you
there's an online city as well so you
can connect with people there and they
tend to meet not only online but then
folks in those cities meet once a month
and then share stories and provide
support for other people around you
that's a great way to meet new friends i
love that we have a question here from
christopher on instagram where is the
best place to find a long-term partner
or spouse
well you said tinder earlier so you
can't use that answer again right uh i
mean i did meet mariah on okcupid um
which is funny because if you were to
tell my like you know 20 year old self
you're going to meet the love of your
life online i would have been like i
don't know what that is
or i would have been like
how did things go so south that's right
like what happened to me where i had to
resort to meeting someone online what
did i do wrong yeah right but now it's a
place where a lot of people go and there
are good reasons for that the algorithms
matched you up but you don't have to be
limited to that either my wife and i met
in a grocery store
and and so you can meet at a grocery
store
you can meet at
okcupid or match.com or wherever
john i would love to hear your
perspective on this because i think this
is another thing that we do we quite
often go seeking the other person i need
my other half i need someone to complete
me it's a story that we tell ourselves
your new book by the way own your past
change your future is
the book that's really about the stories
we tell ourselves they're the problem
we're creating all these problems in our
lives with these stories but also new
empowering stories are the solution and
so i found for me one empowering story
has much more to do with i don't need
someone else to complete me i am already
complete
and regardless of what your your faith
tradition is some people say well yeah
you're complete but with jesus
even then it's like i i understand what
you're saying but still my spouse
doesn't complete me even in that
scenario but that
i found love when i stopped obsessively
seeking it out yes so
let's back out
from
1920 to world history all until the dawn
of time yes
marriages were served two primary
functions either to expand somebody
else's
political or financial gain right my dad
was friends with ryan's dad and so
he
um
we we were matched with spouses so that
we could expand territory okay yes or
we looked at a spouse and said uh a
human another human and said life's
pretty much miserable and short and
we're gonna die you you wanna just do
miserable and short death with me and we
would have a bunch of kids and try to
make a romantic try to have food and
here's the thing after 10 15 25 30 and
then into the 1900s 50 60 years together
right you became soul mates we breathe
the same air we thought the same
thoughts we ate the same meals because
we did them together we we raised the
same chickens
and then all of a sudden and again i'm
i'm compressing time here jerry maguire
comes out and tom cruise looks across
the room and says you complete me and
that's not the moment but it's just fun
to point at that
suddenly we decided to reverse engineer
the
soul mate
i'm going to find the right person and
then we're going to backfill it my my uh
my grandparents celebrated 72 years of
marriage before they died
and when my granddad died my grandmother
basically said i'm out because
part of me is gone
when you're 22 and you're looking around
like where's my other half where's my
other half that's not how that works
right and so i find you to make me feel
good and feelings as a prop as a proxy
for love i have about a week and a half
of of
jet fuel in them and that sucker's gone
then i have to decide every miserable
day
you're the person i'm gonna choose to
love today and that is not that was not
in titanic that wasn't in any tom cruise
movie like how do you stay married i
just wake up and decide i'm going to
love you and i'm going to put my needs
behind yours and hopefully you'll put
your needs behind
your knee my needs behind yours and
we're going to do this on a loop for the
rest of our lives right
it's it's
stopping trying to reverse engineer that
process so people say like hey how do i
find love i don't choose
she's love and i know it's not sexy and
it's not cool and it's not like hip what
just choose love and make that choice
every day for the rest of your life hmm
but but that's not you know
that's not uh rom-com style love that's
miserable it's not nearly as exciting as
yeah as some rom-com no man i yeah i
love that because like i do that with
mariah like every
morning i wake up she's unlovable and
you choose to love her every morning
exactly
no it's really i'm not here i'm
unwonderful i'm unlovable and she
chooses to love me which inspires me to
be a better person but yeah no like
waking up and choosing to be there is um
that's so much more powerful than like
living off of that ephemeral
uh you know um
infatuation whatever that high is when
you first meet someone and it's
it's yeah it's interesting because you
can get that that that infatuation
feeling with a lot of different people
but it's the long haul stuff like that's
really where a good relationship matches
up is when you you can look at that
person like oh i can i could wake up
next to this person every morning
whether i have this infatuating feeling
or not
love like and lust these are three
components of any intimate relationship
too often we we get that chemistry up
front the lust and it's like oh this
must be love at first sight it must be
you know storybook rom-com whatever you
want to call it right and and so we get
confused and say this lust which is a
key component in fact it's one of the
reasons that marriages break up long
term is they've lost that chemistry
right and so when people lose that
chemistry quite often they stray they
seek novelty through other relationships
right and so
maintaining that is still important the
love part is actually in in many ways
the easiest and the hardest
to love someone is to see them for who
who they are without trying to change
them without trying to force change onto
someone right and so i'm going to drag
you to my singularly correct world view
and that means i'm right and if i can
drag you over to my rightness then you
will be right with me and and well no
that's not love that's the opposite of
love that's conditional love there's no
such thing as conditional love love
doesn't have conditions like often has
conditions and that's the third
component and this is i think the most
difficult in any relationship is finding
someone with whom we are compatible
someone you like and it may be that you
can love every part of someone without
liking every action or behavior in their
life and being able to accept those
behaviors is what love is all about oh
there's oftentimes my wife doesn't like
me she loves me
man and she tells me you can be a lot
right and so i don't like all the stuff
i think that's i think that's super wise
i've been compelled by again to go back
to perel's work she talks about
when you are infatuated with somebody
when you were lusting over somebody
you're in love with them
in that season you practice safety
are they going to show up on a call
we agreed that we're going to have a
date at this time on this at on this
particular day will they be there we
practice safety is this person open the
door for me is this person are they
respectful to other people around
and once your body achieves safety it
stops pumping oxytocin and other drugs
through you right so lust you're high
you're high right when the high wears
off
what we don't have in our society is a
way to practice
um intimacy to practice
desire
we have a lot of how do you practice
safety
we don't have practice desire and love
and intimacy and desire
does not is not compatible with safety
so when i've established safety in my
relationship then i have to be about a
way more fun
practice for the rest of my life is
practicing desire how do i lean in and
continue to practice
i get to practice lost i get to practice
desire because i know she's going to be
there she said she was going to be there
now i get to practice the fun stuff
right and we have no cultural ethos for
that what we say is if that wears off
then y'all weren't meant to be the
relationships run its course this
thing's over you need to move on that
person has served their utility in your
world and it's time to go to the next
one and now no man you get to practice
desire and all the reckless crazy risky
ways that is what a fun way to live life
right um
yeah well well the opposite of that
would be to
to
accept the fact that
there you've lost the desire and then
you sort of become complacent in the
relationship i find that uh my wife and
i we she has a podcast called how to
love and i co-host it with her and we
talk about these these conversations
and
what we often talk about is like
creating that novelty within the
relationship creating the distance which
brings you back together that's right
right
and because if you don't do that
then then you will lose that important
component that chemistry component it's
not the most important thing it's like
if you have a a table that has three
legs love like and lust
you knock one leg out the whole table
the whole relationship
falls over let's move on to some callers
here if you have a question or comment
for our podcast give us a call 406
219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at
theminimalists.com we have a question
here from justin in illinois right now i
just want to get some
tips on
basically putting my life on hold
whether
or not to
move basically i have a daughter and i
want to
be in her life
at the same time i have a job that is
really crippling me and has a lot of
negativity involved it's not adding any
value to my life and the timing with my
daughter is limited so if you can give
any tips on putting what you value and
kind of chasing after that as opposed to
holding on to a job which contains your
you know
i have my health insurance my life
insurance
car insurance all that stuff through
them um how long do you do you really
want to put that stuff on hold
so john you
talk about this quite a bit on your show
which folks can check out on youtube by
the way people call in all the time and
some of the craziest calls is like my
wife has cheated on me three times today
and also uh my boss fired me this
morning what do i do
and so you you deal with some of these
complex problems but like what justin is
saying here
your
your book really covers this because you
you talk about the stories that we tell
ourselves and right now one of the
stories is he's given himself the either
or story
and so maybe you what would you say to
justin any time you've backed yourself
into an either or corner you need to go
talk to somebody
because you have
you've limited your options moving
forward and very very rarely do we only
have two options moving forward very
very rarely
um
i would love for was his name justin
yeah i'd love for justin to go back and
listen to the call because he answers it
himself
he is drowning himself with car
insurance and health insurance and a 401
match
he knows that he's dying
yet he lives in a culture where the
story used to be our religious
institutions told us what to wear what
to believe how to function who's who who
got to own property who did all the
stuff and we pulled the threat on that
one
and then we moved to you complete me to
our spouses we dumped everything on them
and that one lasted about 25 years and
we've looked around we've burned our
spouses to the ground right
and our last great bastion of human
connection is work and so now we've
taken our identities and our self-worth
and everything about us and we've dumped
it into the workplace and said y'all
solve us
and so he has a little girl who is
saying to herself every day what is it
about that place that is more lovable
than me
and he is asking himself why am i doing
this
he can't unhook himself from that last
great vacuum right it's like reminds me
of spaceballs with
mega made she's just like sucking that
dude in right like
he asks when should i
right now
right now and if you have to sell your
house and move to a one-bedroom
apartment to reconnect with your
daughter and work down the street for 14
hour right now
and you will find peace and freedom and
a clarity to then say what i do next
but dude right now you know what i mean
you don't have time to wait on those
kind of calls mm-hmm yeah
yeah it's
i don't know it makes me think of when
i first started the whole
minimalism journey uh we started the
blog i was still working on my corporate
job for about a year and then i got laid
off
and you know luckily i had been
preparing myself to
leave that job eventually
and the amount of clarity that i was
able to gain
after i got laid off just kind of seeing
a path forward and looking at different
options i never would have seen those
different options if i if i didn't get
laid off yeah and thank god they laid me
off because i kept telling myself i'll
quit next month no i'll put on my two
weeks notice the next month and i kept
putting it off um and it was kind of
forced upon me but you know really what
justin's looking for here is security
he's looking for some certainty and we
all need some security and certainty and
he's finding it right now in health
insurance and car insurance in the 401k
match
but you know justin i would uh i would
challenge you to look at what what are
your bare necessities to really feel
secure
because a 401k match is a great thing
awesome it's it's amazing um but
you don't need that to feel secure yeah
there's
there's some there's a very interesting
phrase that he used in the call when
he's considering putting his life on
hold
and what i would say is you've already
done that
and so why not consider taking your life
off hold on push play on your life it's
time to press play it may not look like
what society has dictated with the 401k
match and the so-called perfect job
because guess what that perfect job is
making you miserable so how perfect
could it be
in the first place justin i'd love to
send you a copy of an event that we did
so
john ryan and i we were in houston
during the love people use things tour a
few months ago and we released this live
event to all of our patreon supporters
patreon.com the minimalist if you're a
true fan or vip over there you have
access to all 20 of those love people
use things events including the houston
event so justin i think you'll find a
lot of value because we dove deep into a
lot of questions very similar to this
during that live event in houston
anyone else who's interested you can
find all of our previous live events and
our upcoming live events at
theminimalists.com
tour but justin we'll send you a video
version of that houston event with jo
with dr john delony thank you ryan what
time is it it's time for the lending
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions your
comments your smart remarks to 937
937-202-4654
yes indeed now those texts go to both of
our phones we actually respond to some
folks personally and um i'll tell you
this during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i and our guests we try
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call them minimal maxims we
put them in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place minimalmaxims.com
but john don't worry we just monitor on
it who's gonna say man like my wife
would love me to have this skill can you
just say it in one sentence please i
don't know what you're talking about
this would be great well we've got your
text messages here we've got one from
stacy what does stacey have for us how
do we transition from an overabundance
of acquaintances into fewer more
meaningful relationships john let's talk
about this because this question
presupposes
that what we should do is have
fewer relationships and as we've already
alluded to in like ryan's of my
relationship i have fewer
close relationships than ryan has and
that's what's appropriate for me and if
we were to flip-flop the amount of
relationships it would be
off for both of us so here's here's my
pithy answer and maybe we can expand on
it together less isn't always better but
too much is too much every time
and so
what is too much for you is going to be
different for what is too much for me
just having six close relationships
might be too much for me having 60 might
not be enough for ryan
and so understanding what your enough
point is
is really what you're where you'll find
contentment with those relationships
however
where stacy's sitting right now she says
she has
an over abundance of acquaintances
and she's look and she doesn't find
those to be meaningful
why might that be
i think she's
i think she's leaning too heavily into
the shoulds
leading too heavily into the
what i'm supposed to be doing
somebody somewhere told her
why do you have so many friends you only
need three or four yeah and that voice
haunts her or she grew up in a home
where mom only had one friend that she
just called and gossiped with every day
or dad had no friends he just watched tv
and until he passed out on the couch and
repeat and repeat and repeat so she has
this picture
of what friendship's supposed to look
like especially as an adult and it is
running up against the narrative of the
world of her actual true experience that
she has created a a life full of human
beings that interact with her all the
time
and i always want people to challenge
the moment that word comes out of your
mouth i should be stopped
why
where does that story come from is your
body telling you that or is brian
telling you that and pull that thread
and often shoulds are right they're
right i should brush my teeth as
communicated by my loved ones and
friends right and my dentist i should
exercise every morning because i feel
better and fill in the blank
every should should be should be
traveled and even understanding those
shoulds are still constructs right
because they are the the people who have
the nicest teeth i've ever seen are the
maasai and they've never even met a
toothbrush
right and so we have to also understand
that like even that should that is
appropriate in my culture or from the
should that is appropriate for me right
now isn't a universal there's levels and
layers that's right that's right that's
right yeah so we should question our
shoulds yes oh i like that but the the
true question is i have i mean the true
answer is in this particular case
i have a group of people that
when something goes down i instantly
call
right so when i used to coach high
school track and whenever we're trying
to establish a lead leg like how to get
into the blocks or someone's going to do
high jump or long jump
and you're trying to help some a young
kid figure out his leg all you do is
walk behind him and just push him
and if you just push them they'll put a
leg out to stop themselves from falling
that's their lead leg and so
imagine do a thought experiment
all of a sudden i've got to call a
friend to come
pick up my dog because i got to go be
with my mom who do i call
yeah that's your person
i'm gonna call these two of these three
people i'm gonna call her i can't call
her she'd never that's not your person
right so put yourself in that position
where you have to lean forward just a
little bit and ask yourself who would
you call and let's set up a recurring
book club with them or recruiting a
recurring gratitude club with them or a
dinner group or whatever and let's lean
into those relationships oh i like the
gratitude club thing and how do i serve
those relationships as well that's right
not transactionally i'll give to this so
i can get something from it later this
is not an investment account that's
right but also like if they're showing
up for me why aren't i showing up for
them in whatever capacity i can and
recognizing that's going to be different
just because that other person can't
show up for you that's not moralize it
either just that like you said that's
not your person that's not a good or a
bad thing but understanding that helps
us understand how to navigate those
relationships yeah
oh my fifth answer is this uh
it's hard to be a friend
when you are your own worst enemy so
regardless of how many people
uh this person
uh uh stacy regardless of how many
people stacy's hanging out with if she
doesn't have a good relationship with
herself she's not gonna be able to be a
good friend to the people around her so
uh i don't know that's that's the first
question i would ask myself is like how
do i feel about um about myself how do i
feel like what i can give to the world
rather than uh what does melbourne think
i should do what's the appropriate
amount of friends and
it reminded me of
a gandhi story
he said i have only three enemies in
this whole world the first one is the
entire british empire
because
i can deal with them fairly easy because
they're so far away like it's it's not a
big deal it's my second enemy are all of
my indian
friends and family by indian countrymen
they're a little bit harder to deal with
because they're right here and i have to
face them my third enemy his name is
mahatma kay gandhi
and i seem to have no control over him
whatsoever
and
that is exactly what ryan is describing
here with
you
it's hard to be
a friend or best friend towards someone
else when you're constantly your own
worst enemy how do you
be better friends with someone else by
stop being that enemy with yourself
so my pity answer would be
along your
don't outsource your life i have a
friend who's got a water bottle that
reminds her when to drink
like we've outsourced thirst we've
outsourced our step counting we've
outsourced everything
even as stacy has
uh how many friends should i have we've
outsourced connection yeah we've
outsourced the the
the level of connection to
some guys on a podcast right yeah what
is your body telling you when it comes
to being around other people right right
don't outsource your life amen because
if you try to live a life that is
identical to mine how many friends does
he have because that's how many i should
have yes or that might make you
miserable or oh that didn't work so how
many friends does ryan have yeah now how
many friends does john have and then
i'll approximate that and then it's
finding approximate levels of misery
really right
real quickly we've got a segment here
called right here right now we talk
about one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist and since john is
here john works for this guy named dave
ramsey ramsey solutions
and uh we've been partnered up with them
and uh this month and last month
here's what we're trying to do ryan and
i come from a poor city it's called
dayton ohio
and um
people call in to your show and to the
ramsey show all the time
and i hear these stories of people
i'm 29 years old with a million dollars
worth of debt
i'm 43 years old with 733 000 worth of
debt i'm 68 years old i'm still paying
off my student loans
and i want to be like hey how how can i
go into the past and help these people
we haven't found a time machine yet but
the closest thing i have is maybe we can
go into the past
from the future
which is right now and we can help some
people in dayton ohio so ryan and i have
set out we said we're going to provide
financial teaching we're going to teach
the the foundations of personal finance
which is a school curriculum
in every middle school to every middle
schooler and every high school to every
high schooler in dayton ohio so every
middle schooler
every high schooler in dayton ohio
we are going to provide financial
literacy training so they're not
burdened by debt for the rest of their
lives
i really wish i would have had this
training when we went to school in ohio
back in the 1900s
oh my god
i've never felt so old you know the only
training i ever got was
in a specific it was like a
extracurricular class i don't know home
equity you know something like that
and they sat down it was my senior year
they sat you down and they were like
okay we're gonna help you budget we're
gonna help you see how much you need to
actually live
and it was a great exercise because you
know it turned out i needed way less
than what i thought i needed to like
actually make rent and you know pay for
insurance and stuff but i remember
a piece of this puzzle was okay so a car
a car payment's gonna it averages this
you know house payment averages that
and it wasn't even about hey stay out of
debt it was just like well i'll help you
factor in your loan payments that's
right and there's nothing wrong with
getting a loan but man it would be such
a it would have been such an amazing
thing if they approached it in a way of
like hey let's talk about first how you
can do this without getting a loan
um but yeah yeah yeah it's not i don't
want to make anyone feel bad for having
a mortgage or a car payment that's not
the point of this
um but certainly whoever has that
mortgage payment or that car payment if
i can wave a magic wand and make it go
away they would be very grateful for
that i'm sure
it's the idea of of we outsource life
right we just
ask other people what's the right next
step and it's like well you got your
first big job so you got to go get your
first big car and it just comes with a
payment that's just part of it and
before you got your first big job you
had to go to the fanciest possible
college you could go to and i've worked
in universities for 20 years that was my
job before
i am doing whatever this is now and
i
like
i got to go to the best college and then
we figure out costs later and there's
somebody else that will just write a
check for the tab until we get through
and then we'll figure that out later and
then like you mentioned the numbers you
threw out are real numbers but they can
get cartoonish
most people are carrying about 75 80 100
000 of combined debt in their house yeah
and we don't have that we don't have
that we're drowning i didn't know y'all
were doing this i work in the building
this is incredible one that's not i i
keep my head in the sand most time but
this isn't me i'm gonna put money in on
y'all's thing i'm really grateful here's
what i love here's what i love
it is
the only way forward in my estimation
after sitting with hurting people for so
long is people have to circle up and
start loving locally mm-hmm
let's put the let's put our differences
let's put that stuff in a box great
here's a problem and you all have said
i'm going to go circle up in my hometown
with to help a group of like of 12 to 18
year olds because nobody else is nobody
else is and i'll partner with you and
i'll partner with you and i'll partner
with you we're going to figure this out
the goal is to help those kids
because at some point this bill comes
due right what are we 30 trillion so i
mean at some point the bill comes due
and man that's like that's a lot that's
like a
it's a it's a level of putting your
money in your mouth is it i don't see
very often so i'm i'm i'm encouraged to
i've never even been to dayton ohio but
i'm in man i'm in i love i love it thank
you well so ryan and i we contributed
personally we are helping the first 100
students awesome with with our own money
if folks want to contribute it's just
the minimalists.com education 25
provides curriculum for one middle
school student 45 for a high school
student if you can give more than that
great or if you can only give five
dollars please do you're contributing to
help kids
not borrow from their future they're
going to avoid debt ryan and i have done
10 philanthropic projects over the last
dozen years we've built orphanages we've
funded high schools we built an
elementary school we built a non-profit
groceries
in
the biggest food desert in the country
in in dayton
and this is the thing that i've been
most excited about
because
we're
helping people
not go into debt not create because the
average
indebted household in america
ninety seven thousand seven hundred and
seventy five dollars in non-mortgage
debt that's credit card debt student
loans
car payments etc right a hundred
thousand dollars
and you get there
and all of a sudden you're like oh my
gosh how did i how did this happen well
i did everything i was supposed
to do right by the way we're also going
to be
uh in nashville franklin tennessee if
you're going to stop by and see us on
may 9th we got sarah and megan here from
ramsay solutions as well we're going to
be on the ramsey show back again i think
it's our fifth appearance
and uh so if you want to come by they
have a whole lobby where you can watch
the show it's it's really awesome coffee
cookies it's important to note i think
it's one out of two it's 40 of high
schools and middle schools across the
country have this
educational curriculum i didn't know it
existed and the goal is to make it i
think a state or two just recently
passed
every you can't graduate high school
without going through some sort of
financial literacy conversation because
look man we gotta help these kids yeah
cause the adults aren't right we the
adults have not put a good example
forward no right and again it's not
about shame it's about owning reality
look in the mirror and say if i could
have done this differently would i yes
yeah let's be about doing that right
yeah awesome up until now many of us
ryan and i included have been part of
the problem when we were in the
corporate world not that corporations
are inherently evil i mean even
non-profits are corporations right and
so we're not saying that corporations
are evil but what you do when you
manufacture these false desires for
things that people don't need you
encourage them to go into debt to buy
these things
you're creating
a bit of the anxiety the stress the
discontent in our society and at this
point we're trying to be part of the
solution by preventing it going forward
if you want to contribute we can really
use your help
if we get past our initial goal we'll be
able to expand to other markets beyond
dayton ohio as well so you can find all
the details all the good stuff the
minimalists dot com education you can
donate right there all the frequently
asked questions are on that page as well
alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi my name is jamie i'm calling from los
angeles california i meant to leave this
a long time ago because i feel like it
was on one of the debt episodes
but it actually pertains also to the
budget um
a friend of mine i can't take total
credit for this but recommended that i
check in with my
cell phone bill i had noticed it was
really high for two cell phones
and i admit even though i'm very
organized when the bill comes
electronically
i don't always look at it
so i won't give the provider a name per
se but i did call
i asked to make my bill lower
which they did have something to offer
but then we combed through the bill on
the phone and i had
apparently
some kind of featured at 399 a month for
international calling i never call
international calling
so that came off i had some kind of
ringtone charge that was happening i
didn't know about
anyway long story short i found all
kinds of hidden charges that i did not
know that were happening for years
i lowered my bill right then and there
by sixty dollars
um i wanted to wait a few months to see
if it actually stayed that way
and it has so it's been about six months
um
so
when we get bills electronically we
don't always look at them so um i just
urge people to check in to especially a
cell phone bill that has some of these
charges we might not even know because
60 dollars times 12 months of the year
has been a huge savings for me
as i try to get out of debt
hi this is joe in dallas and i was
burning through some old minimalist
podcasts
and i heard you talking about the
ketogenic diet and cure bacon and i just
wanted to throw out there that they do
sell uncured bacon in a lot of places
now including walmart
that have less than one gram of carbs
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment one thing that i
forgot to mention we're gonna be on the
ramsay show we'll be down at ramsay
solutions on
just like next week it'll be on the 9th
of may
a 2 p.m on that's monday the 9th if you
want to stop by you can get a hug from
us they are free and transferable you
don't have to pay us anything for a hug
free and transferable where was that
line when i was in middle school man
that would have been fantastic you could
do that with your daughter we talked
about that on the maximal episode
yes or what i always say to ryan is let
me steal some of those electrons i love
it i love it you're big into grounding
so you usually you know about the
electron thing and so crazy i'm
constantly going around that's the main
reason we hug people is just to take
their electrode yeah we take all their
energy
and then we use it to rule the world
stop by the uh the ramsay show if you're
anywhere near tennessee if you just want
to drive down it's in franklin tennessee
we'll be there 2 p.m on
monday may 9th before we get to our
added value segment i just want to say
thanks real quick to dr john deloney his
new book is called own your past change
your future i'll hold this up if you're
watching on youtube it's a book about
the stories we tell ourselves how
they're disempowering and also how we
can change those stories into something
that is more empowering something that
is actually going to solve the problem
instead of creating more problems with
those stories
also you can check out his show it's
called the dr john delony show you can
find youtube we'll put a link to it in
the show notes as well anywhere else we
should send folks to see you
um you can follow me at john delony on
the internets i'm still figuring out how
all that stuff works but i'm i'm getting
better i i think i tell myself right and
um and the youtube show is also a
podcast you can get wherever you get
podcast after you listen to the
minimalists
roll over and you can pick up my show
too yeah i think 90 plus percent of our
audience is audio so if you're listening
to the audio version of this and you
prefer audio you can check out the uh
the podcast version wherever you i have
a face for for for podcasting
that's probably gonna get out
man
for our added value segment this week we
talk about one thing that's added value
to our lives recently
my favorite comedian since we were
talking about comedians on the maximal
episode we were really talking about
john told this great story about i won't
go into the details but like he dealt
with some really traumatic situation his
job was to deal with some traumatic
situations the only way he could handle
that was by injecting some comedy some
humor some levity into those situations
so my favorite comedian he's named
gerard carmichael
and
my favorite special of his came out a
few years ago i think in 2016. it was
called eight
like the number eight and
he just had this new special come out
and it's called rathaniel
i won't give away any spoilers here but
he deals with some serious trauma in his
own life
the best way he can through
jokes through humor
not beating people up with the humor but
opening the door to healing some of that
trauma that he's experienced for you
know 35 years however long he's been
on this earth
and what you realize is that we all go
through some of these things some of
these stories that we tell ourselves and
the way that he got out of these
disempowering stories
was to be
funny was to approach it with candor and
humor
add some lightness to it otherwise it
becomes really difficult to carry
yeah so you can check that out it's on
hbo
it's called rathaniel by gerard
carmichael
by the way we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what is the
cure for crippling anxiety
what are the different types of anxiety
and how can they contribute to unhealthy
coping mechanisms how do i break out of
the cycle of transactional based
relationships plus a million more
questions for dr deloney and the
minimalist if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you
you can follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and uh podcast peter i don't
know why i haven't been mentioning him
in the notes here as well shout out to
all of them and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn if you leave here
today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it